l'association réunir organise chaque
mois des ateliers de cuisine à
destination des familles en partenariat
avec l'association ctp obésité des
ateliers qui permettent d'aborder lé
équilibre alimentaire de manière
pratique mais aussi de démontrer qu'il
est possible de concilier plaisir et
équilibre dans l'assiette
alors aujourd'hui on l'atelier cuisine
qui se fait dans le cadre du programme
d'éducation thérapeutique proposé à
l'association réunir et en fait on
propose aux familles qui veulent
participer à des ateliers cuisine est
régulièrement
on a fait une par mois et on leur
propose un menu équilibré avec beaucoup
de légumes et beaucoup de fruits on va
tous ensemble mangé ce midi le repas
réalisé pour les parents présents à cet
atelier c'est l'occasion de découvrir de
nouvelles recettes et d'initier leurs
enfants à une alimentation équilibrée et
diversifiée
ça parce que ça donne des idées de
recettes à faire à la maison avec les
enfants pour les inciter à manger plus
de légumes
c'est la première fois que je participe
à ce ateliers pour moi pour l'instant
c'est agréable avec les autres
confondues sont là mais accuse une houle
apprendre à cuisiner les légumes le
poisson pour menu beaucoup de fruits et
légumes du poisson mais toutefois les
recettes qui sortent de l'ordinaire
alors aujourd'hui on prépare un velouté
froid de betteraves en entrée en plat de
résistance et papillotes de poisson
accompagné de ses légumes ensuite il ya
une sauce qui accompagne le patient
c'est sa citroën serbe et dépendent de
terre et des couches au four et au
dessert ou partenaires à la fraîche
fort de son expérience et du soutien de
ses partenaires l'association réunir
développe son action pour les familles
réunionnaises et leurs enfants
le conseil départemental se mobilisent
depuis de nombreuses années dans la
lutte contre l'obésité
le conseil départemental apporte
effectivement une aide financière par
rapport à au programme qu'on propose aux
familles donc au niveau des séances
d'éducation de nutritionnelle au niveau
des parents et puis au niveau des
ateliers cuisine égal si vous souhaitez
également participé à ces ateliers de
cuisine contacter l'association réunir
au 02 62 35 08 35